the Joe Rogan experience it's a crazy
thing that you've done and it begs the
question when you do crazy things like
does this change you as a person does
like you walk across an articles one
rowing across the Drake stretch as it
was great passage is another like is
this changing you as a person like what
are these because these are experiences
way if you told someone hey you're gonna
sleep 90 minutes out of at a clip then
you're gonna row for 90 minutes and
you're gonna poop into a bucket and
you're gonna sleep it's like a sardine
with a bunch other dudes on this boat
you're not gonna sleep much you're
probably gonna hallucinate sometimes
you're gonna row in the dark
I think songs yeah you'll get through it
though couple weeks later you'll be done
yeah like these these are weird things
that you're doing that's sort of
changing your personal life experiences
are so much more extreme than the
average person's yeah a hundred percent
I mean you know one of my reasons for
doing this for sure is to test the
limits of my own potential and grow I'm
not doing them just to like so that I
can be the exact same person on the
other side of Antarctica or the other
side of Drake Passage it's to take that
learning and you know I've been asked a
similar question I guess before when my
answer or the way that I kind of think
about it is I've started to think about
life like the I mean I've started think
about life in the totality of life
experience between like say a numerical
one and ten like one being the worst day
of your life and ten being the best day
of your life and you know one might be
you know a day that if a family member
passes away or one might be being wet
and cold and freezing in an ocean row
boats you know spooning with this other
guy and you know been [ __ ] in a bucket
and being exhausted and tired you know
like just like rough moments in your
life right and ten is this hedonistic
joy the most pleasure field day ever
it's just happy joyful maybe you've
succeeded in something you've
accomplished like always kind of stuff
and as I've kind of looked around at the
world people say what are you afraid of
you must not be afraid of being alone or
you must not be afraid of you know these
hard challenges or stuff like that I'm
like mom maybe not but what I'm really
afraid of is actually living a life
range bound between four and six I think
too often
people you know the typical life
experience unfortunately because we have
some creature comforts particularly in
the Western world where you know you can
live a life and just stuck between four
and six so maybe the happiest day of
your year your week it's like the
Superbowl and your team wins a Superbowl
and you crush a couple beers with your
buddy and you high-five me like oh that
was awesome like that was cool but it's
not ten I mean it's a six and then like
maybe the worst day your week it's like
a Monday and your boss yells at you or
something like that and you're just like
you're like oh man like that's kind of
bummer but you know I don't really give
a [ __ ] about my job anyway so like I'm
not really that bummed about I just like
is I can just kind of like in this like
life of like quiet desperation in the
middle and I think a lot of that has to
do with because we're hedging or we're
afraid of the ones we're just like I
don't want to experience of one I don't
want to experience discomfort I don't
want to experience pain like let
anything to do that but what I've
realized I think of it like kind of a
pendulum like swinging the totality of
life experience like to get to the tens
you also need to embrace the ones like
the totality of life in the experience
it's not I'm not experiencing these high
highs or these hedonistic Gorge of these
beautiful flow states or things like
that you know in spite of the ones in
spite of the challenge but it's because
of them yeah by pulling my sled you know
53 days on my 53rd day of pulling my
sled across Antarctica I get there my
hips are poking out my ribs are sticking
out I'm exhausted
I can barely pick my duffel bag up to
put it my sled my body's completely
compromised I'm exhausted but then I tap
into the deepest flow state of my entire
life
I find this place in my mind in my body
and my soul and you know I pushed 32
hours without stopping to the finish
line and I wouldn't have gotten there
how do I not push myself had I not you
know gone through this difficulty you
know I like to say that you know pain is
mandatory these challenges are painful
straight-up pain is mandatory make no
mistake about this obvious things I'm
doing are painful they're hard whatever
but the suffering part is optional yeah
you know you don't have to be in these
moments so when I drink oh my god this
is horrible I'm in this and why did I
get myself out there's a terrible above
above above and go down this path you're
like I'm doing this because when I step
outside of my comfort zone I grow and as
I grow I can share that with other
people and hopefully have that ripple
effect of positivity and inspiration
that's lasting in the world for others
as well yeah you mentioned one of my
ever quotes over the Thoreau quote most
men live lives of quiet desperation yeah
that's a lot rate [ __ ] quote and so
damn true I think you're right I think
you really need very difficult things in
your life in order to appreciate real
comfort and relaxation absolutely I
don't think you hit it if you just if
your whole life is just soft cushions
and everything's made out of a lure and
people are feeding you grapes I think
you live like an [ __ ] yeah I think
you know we don't like that because no
one really suffering is hard it's hard
it feels uncomfortable but you don't
realize that unless you suffer you don't
appreciate calm you don't appreciate
peace I think there's just far too many
people out there seeking comfort I agree
with that and I think that it's funny
because people are going towards that
they're hedging against discomfort like
okay well how to make this as
comfortable as possible and then they
sit there and they're like why am i
unsatisfied why am I not happy but it's
like because you're hedging against
discomfort because you're trying to make
like you said it's poor education really
people are not educated on what it takes
in order to be fulfilled in life the
idea is that material possessions or
some modicum of success is the goal it's
not you know difficult tasks is what
make you make you do something that's
hard to do do something that's
interesting do something that's
complicated and intricate do something
that requires you to stretch your
boundaries
[Applause]